now around a dozen people have been
injured in southern lebanon after a huge
explosion rocked a palestinian refugee
camp in the port city of tyre
lebanese media say the blast occurred at
a weapons depot of the palestinian
militant group hamas inside the camp
security sources say a fire triggered by
the explosion has now been brought under
control
and for more we can talk to ancel
chalvora in beirut she's the middle east
columnist with foreign policy magazine
and shel thanks for your time what more
do we know at this point about the blast
well you know this incident
yet again reveals how this country is
grappling with crises and how these
prices often lead to disaster there's a
fuel crisis here so people are buying
fuel when they can get their hands on it
and in this case there was a tank full
of diesel this diesel tank apparently
first caught fire and then this fire
spread to a mosque which uh according to
what we've learned
had weapons uh that belonged to hamas
which is a palestinian militant
political group as it is uh sort of
referred to here uh and uh that is what
caused these injuries now the state
media said that there have been
casualties too but so far there is no
numbers to you know how many uh
casualties there are but as you earlier
mentioned a dozen people uh have in fact
suffered injuries an interesting uh note
that i'd like to add that is really
think tank and this is a think tank that
sort of looks at the security in the in
the region regarding israel has said has
rather claimed that this was a training
complex of
the palestinian movement or militant
group hamas
this of course isn't the only
palestinian refugee camp in lebanon can
you tell us a little bit more about them
the situation there
well absolutely there are about a dozen
palestinian camps and most of these
camps are cramped very congested areas
this is believed to be the second most
congested camp in all of lebanon it is
quite near the border uh uh we also sort
of uh you know we know that hamas has
weapons we know that the security in
this camps is the responsibility of the
palestinians and that is because of the
long civil war that this country has
faced uh 15 years long civil war and the
palestinians and lebanese have had
several issues in the past so security
in these camps is essentially the task
of either palestinian liberation
organization
or hamas so the lebanese armed forces
actually cannot go in so you've got a
situation where there are a lot of
people uh civic communities
uh you know a rare thing and uh uh there
are groups with weapons
ancho vora in beirut thank you so much
for that update